[Music]
[Applause]
graduates
guests faculty and staff
welcome to the 2021 graduation ceremony
at the stamford university graduate
school of business
honestly after 15 months
it's a bit hard to believe that we're
here together
in frost amphitheater but it sure
feels great
let's take a moment to appreciate just
being together
okay now as we begin i'd like to ask the
graduates to rise
and to turn and face the audience
[Music]
[Applause]
and now i'd like to recognize our guests
the families and friends who have
provided support and made the effort to
be here today
let's have a round of applause for our
guests
please be seated
last week i recorded a podcast with a
gsb alumnus
he was curious about graduation he asked
what's distinctive about the graduating
class and
do you have a theme for graduation
the first question was easy you arrived
at the gsb
for more than 60 countries investors
consultants entrepreneurs
activists olympians surprisingly good
dancers
and formed a historically resilient
class
the second question made me think i said
my theme is optimism
let me tell you a favorite story about
optimism
in 1914 the great polar explorer ernest
shackleton
set out to attempt the first crossing of
antarctica
as he and his crew neared land his ship
the endurance
was crushed in the sea ice stranding
them for an antarctic winter
and for more than a year eventually they
managed to reach
a remote island with no rescue coming
shackleton took five men and set out on
the open sea in a 22-foot wooden
lifeboat
they sailed 800 miles through some of
the most treacherous water on the planet
to south georgia island arriving on the
wrong side of the island
they attach nails to their boots and
with a single makeshift ice axe
and a 50-foot piece of rope they crossed
the mountains to a whaling station
everyone in the expedition was saved
later a reporter asked shackleton if he
believed the men would survive
shackleton said
of course he had he said
the quality i look for most is optimism
especially optimism in the face of
reverses
and apparent defeats optimism
is true moral courage
i am sometimes accused fairly of being
an optimist
but let me be clear about the meaning of
the word and how i think
shackleton was using it
optimism does not mean having the naive
sense that everything is fine
or will simply work out optimism comes
from the latin word
optimus meaning the best
optimism means continuing to believe
that the best is possible
and striving for it optimism for
shackleton was a form of courage
not being undone by adversity
but believing salvation was possible and
from that belief drawing the strength to
make it happen
fifteen months ago this class was dealt
a reverse
an apparent defeat okay
it wasn't being stranded on the ice in
antarctica for an entire winter
some of it involved multiple orders a
week from doordash
and binge watching netflix
but it was a setback and a setback of
global proportions
with consequences for everyone on the
planet
your reaction could have been
disappointment dismay
despair and of course there was some of
that
there were deep personal losses all of
you experienced a year that you hadn't
planned for or necessarily wanted
but in so many cases this class
responded with optimism
you contributed to and helped create the
experience of online learning
you planned and executed major events
and i only had to yell at you for some
of them
you started organizations you engaged
with each other on complex and important
topics including racial equity and
democracy you form strong
lasting friendships we said many times
this year that you don't always get to
choose your circumstances
but you do get to choose what to make of
them you choose chose
to make the most of your gsb experience
and now we're here the pandemic is
ending
at least here there is every reason to
be optimistic about your future
a paradox of the pandemic is that while
limited our lives it also created many
opportunities
you are graduating at a time of enormous
change and acceleration of digital
technology a rethinking of work the
opportunity to build and reshape
organizations
a recognition that business can help
solve the biggest challenges of our time
it is exactly a moment when your
stanford education will be
the most valuable and
more than other classes you've learned
how to deal with uncertainty
and ambiguity and to be adaptable and
resilient
powerful lessons for your career and
life
and that brings me to my final point
about optimism
one of the historical meanings of the
word is the greater good
as you leave the gsb i want to ask
how will you use what you've learned to
contribute to the greater good now in
truth i ask this of every class
i tell them how much i expect of them
and how excited i am
for the contribution they will make but
this year
is special i can say it with more
confidence than ever
because of the ways your unique
experience has prepared you
to be leaders in the world
congratulations i wish you all the best
in your next voyage
and now it's my great pleasure to
introduce jennifer ocher
jennifer ocker is the general atlantic
professor and the culture family faculty
fellow at the stamford gsb
jennifer grew up in california and
attended uc berkeley as an undergraduate
before completing her phd in marketing
here at the gsb
she soon joined the stanford faculty and
has been a gsb professor for more than
20 years
jennifer is a renowned behavioral
scientist she has studied how the desire
for meaning and purpose shapes people's
choices how digital technologies are
redefining human interaction
and how to use humor as a leadership
tool
in fact one of my high points a few
years ago was when jennifer
came to see me speak at a campus event
and as we walked back across campus she
said to me
with some surprise you're funny
looking maybe jennifer's brilliance
energy and insight have garnered her the
gsb's distinguished teaching award and
recognition by poets and quants as the
mba professor of the year as well as
many scholarly awards
she is highly sought after as a speaker
board member and leadership advisor
i counter as a valued friend and
colleague and i'm thrilled to welcome
her as the gsb's 2021
graduation speaker
[Applause]
thank you deans faculty
parents and the graduating class of
stanford business school 2021.
congratulations
i wish you could see you it's absolutely
awe-evoking
you look so good your shoes and your
pants
your three-dimensionality it's so
wonderful to be here
when dean levin asked me to give this
speech i wondered what would you
remember and so i decided to run a study
with alumni and i'm going to ask you the
same questions i asked them
so first think back to the last
graduation you attended
now raise your hands if you remember the
weather
great parents too this is like
collective
all right now raise your hands if you
remember what the commencement
speaker said
oh that's generous uh the alumni
88 of them remembered the weather 18
remembered the speech so i'd like to
just take a moment right now and
really appreciate this weather like
because that is all we're gonna remember
i also asked our alumni for one piece of
advice
they'd like to give you surprisingly
because we're in a business school only
two percent mentioned
business advice the large majority had
lessons from their life
for you one of them was to engage
deeply with this question
what do you believe
constitutes a well-lived life
when i grew up we talked about this
topic all the time because my mom
has been a hospice volunteer for 40
years
and so therefore she's had thousands of
conversations
with people at the end of their lives
where this question comes up
so what i wanted to do with you here
today is share
three insights that are important to me
for a life well lived
based on growing up with my mom number
one
embrace your own unique dimensionality
what this means is creating space and
time
for every part of you to thrive
even if nobody else sees you that way
so here's a snapshot of what that looks
like for me
i got my phd here a long time ago and
so what i would do is outside of
collecting and analyzing data i actually
found myself really loving running
underground
dance clubs so during the week i would
take my courses
and then on thursday evening i'd pack my
bag
i would drive to san francisco i would
throw on
my you know baggy hole filled jeans
throw in some boots
and put on a skull cap and then from 10
to 1
i would work the door at the club and
then from one to four
i would go work on my dissertation in
the back room and then you know when i
needed a break i heard tribe called
quest come on i'd go out and dance
the stanford community hasn't really
seen a dancer
that prolific since dan knapp hit the
scene two years ago
what what whoa
[Applause]
is that phil knight all right
if i tried to align with common
expectations of what a stanford student
was
i wouldn't have had those experiences
which i now remember
far more vividly than all the regression
analyses i ran
everyone is here because some element of
your unique dimensionality brought you
here
now that you're graduating own your
uniqueness
become even more dimensional
unconventional
surprising seek to surprise yourself
keep making bold choices we overestimate
their downside and underestimate their
upside
number two don't take yourself too
seriously
stanford's mission is change lives
change organizations
and change the world and if this year
has taught us nothing else it's that we
must take that mission
seriously but not yourself
here's the problem we all of us
fall off a humor cliff right around the
time we go to work so maybe like for
many of us
in one month what's going to happen is
you will stop smiling and laughing and
you can't make that happen to you
the average four-year-old laughs uh 300
times a day
it takes the average 40-year-old two and
a half
months to laugh that much we can do
better
you've got to do better leaders with a
sense of humor
any sense of humor doesn't even have to
be a good sense of humor it can be
john's sense of humor i'm just joking
they're mo more motivating and admired
and trusted and seen as more authentic
their teams are seen as more creative
and they act in ways that are more
engaging
what happens is when people laugh
together the brain chemistry for all of
us
changes neurochemically essentially what
happens is when you laugh together
it's very similar to the same effect as
exercising
meditating and having sex all at the
same time
but logistically a lot easier
now the question is how can we have more
of it first
know that humor isn't about being funny
which is great
because i have been voted the least
funny person in my family
10 years running after the dog like
like really last it's really about
shifting your mindset
looking at life in a different way and
you do that by simply observing what's
around
you noticing what's true
so you don't ask yourself what joke can
i share
you just ask yourself what's the truth
that no one else is sharing
for example the creators of this year's
gsb
show looked at dean london and saw the
truth
this man is hot
[Applause]
so they created an entire song and dance
number called hot dean levin
if you haven't seen it in the back i've
watched it three times
just this weekend it's spectacular
second when you're playing at the
highest levels
remember to balance gravity with levity
when secretary of state madeleine
albright visited our class
she shared stories of using humor to
disarm
once upon discovering that the russian
government had bugged the state
department
she arrived at her meeting with this
enormous
bug pin on her lapel the russian
counterpart
smiled knew the jig was up and
negotiations went
so much better even in the most serious
moments of your life
and there will be so many relationship
wise and work wise
pause and ask yourself
is there a way to introduce a moment of
levity into that moment
how would that moment be transformed
last end on love
it might seem odd to talk about love at
a business school graduation
but this is not a normal business school
graduation
and the reality is the love that you
feel right now
is the only thing you're going to really
remember
besides this great weather
10 years from now you'll remember your
clay's classmates bringing
home baked cookies during quarantine
you'll remember the glowing smiles like
why need a smile
when you finally saw each other and
embraced each other
you'll remember the raw intimacy of
going to
talks looking right into your classmates
eyes as they bear their soul to you and
let you into their hearts
people may forget what you said people
may forget what you did
but they'll never forget how you made
them feel
what you have gone through in these last
two years and achieved
was not only defined by happy moments
but marked by tragedy pain
uncertainty and resilience
truly meaningful moments and it's those
moments that create durable love
because of your unique shared experience
you
perhaps more than any other graduating
class
truly understand what defines
meaningfulness
in your life how can you take this
knowledge
of what is truly important to drive you
to be bolder
to harness humor with intent even in
serious situations
and to lead with love
when my mom's best friend who was a
second mother to me
was dying we gathered around her bed and
my mom
did with us which she has done with so
many families over the years
she guided us through the dying process
my mom taught us how to hold her hand
and how to breathe with her because if
you breathe with her
she feels connected to you she feels
you're a part of her
my mom shared that the last sense to go
is hearing
so it was important to talk to her and
say it's okay to let go
but you don't actually need to say
goodbye you can just say i love you
today is an ending of sorts but it isn't
goodbye
before closing i want to ask you to do
something
close your eyes
everyone i can tell parents do
i'll check now
imagine someone who loves you deeply
imagine them standing in front of you
take a
deep breath in imagine the way they look
at you
their eyes and their smile
imagine them breathing and you breathing
with them
notice how you feel right now in their
presence
you feel seen you feel known
you feel unconditionally loved
okay open your eyes now take that
feeling and go out in the world
congratulations i love you
it is now my great honor and pleasure to
introduce the gsb
phd class of 2021
our ph.d program is small and exclusive
with an admission rate
under six percent these individuals came
here
as students dedicating themselves to two
or three years of coursework
followed by an intensive research
apprenticeship
in their chosen fields having become
true experts they leave us as colleagues
setting out on a path to create new
knowledge
which we know will help change the world
of business and management for the
better
today we formally celebrate the
transition of these folks
from students to future intellectual
leaders who will play an important role
in shaping our understanding of business
and management
as they cross this stage we welcome them
as colleagues into our profession
diane lee assistant dean of the phd
program
will now read their names in a
description
of their dissertation research
andrew baker andrew researches
corporate governance specifically the
impacts of hedge fund activism
and how and if state corporate law
changes managerial incentives
christopher beckler christopher's
dissertation research addresses
how do people perceive attitude change
how do people choose the targets of
persuasive messages how can these
targeting decisions be improved
wendy jomar de la rosa felipe
wendy's research focuses on
understanding how
and why people make financial decisions
specifically
her dissertation demonstrates how timing
differences
and when consumers get paid such as
getting paid daily versus weekly or
getting paid on fridays versus mondays
impact their spending
stefan huber stefan's dissertation
research
examines how alternative approaches to
measure loan
loss losses affect bank lending
decisions
shreya khan khan haley shreya's research
investigates how small-scale retail
firms in emerging markets
can modernize their physical appearance
in business processes
and the impact of this modernization on
their business performance
she conducts a field experiment with
over one thousand firms in mexico city
finding that both external and internal
modernization
improve retailer revenue over a two-year
horizon
far light bars research provides
insights and tools to better understand
and make market decisions market design
decisions
decisions that are made by online
marketplaces to enhance the welfare
of the marketplace's participants
danshi luo danshi's dissertation
examines the impact of emergency
department congestion
on patients and physicians behaviors and
provides actionable insights
for health care participants to improve
their decisions efficiency
sarah mullick sarah's dissertation
examines whether workers who receive
mandated advance notice of layoffs
have better long-term labor market
outcomes than workers who are laid off
without warning
her research helps policymakers who are
debating
employment protection legislation
suraj's research examines how to
effectively diffuse
information through social networks curb
misinformation from spreading
and regulate the behavior of regulatory
agencies
for each of these problems he shows how
policy makers
can design robust policies when they
have limited information about the
social network
misinformation or regulatory bias
[Music]
govind's research shows that words often
mean different things to different
people
and that this has great impact on who
has good ideas who gets fired
and who gets promoted
andres pearl roth andres's research
provides insights
on the design of optimal policies for
dynamic settings
one setting analyzes what transparency
protocols
are more effective to mitigate posturing
tactics in negotiations
the second setting studies what dynamic
pricing strategy a seller should
implement
to maximize profits
research focuses on entrepreneurship and
healthcare
his research on entrepreneurship
explores how entrepreneurs
can optimally build a business and his
research on health care focuses on
improving efficiency for healthcare
systems
savior warners savior
studies the trade-off between efficiency
and fairness and between welfare and
sustainability
efforts in both case settings he shows
we can increase the latter while
reducing the effects on the former
alyssa you alyssa's dissertation
research explores how we can make sense
of and talk about emotions at work
specifically she examines the risks and
rewards of acknowledging
others emotions on interpersonal
dynamics
information sharing and team performance
rebecca zhang
rebecca's dissertation research focuses
on
corporate social responsibility or esg's
impact on firms financing terms
i am here to introduce the class of 2021
but i hope you will indulge me for a
minute as i paraphrase from one of the
great commencement speeches of all time
the gsb is a place where teachers taught
us to break the status quo
and define define ourselves as we choose
where a jock can cook up a mean creme
brulee and a brainiac can break it down
on the dance floor
those are of course the immortal words
of troy bolton
in high school musical three
okay this group of mba students gathered
before us today
have engaged in a transformational
experience during a unique time in
history
they embarked on this jury journey
before we had heard of covet 19
and persevered through the last 15
months under conditions none of us
expected despite unique challenges
they have acquired solid foundations in
general management
and have pursued deeper study in their
areas of interest
they've engaged in personal growth more
than they probably anticipated
and built relations in novel ways that
will last a lifetime
they are an impressive group and are
ready
and worthy to join the ranks of our
illustrious alumni
therefore it is my great honor and
privilege
to present to you the stanford mba
class of 2021
there are some students who merit
special recognition for the unwavering
leadership and dedication
to serving the student body i'll stick
to the
first names keep it casual emily belinda
kerry and adam the student
stand up will the four of you stand up
the they they are the student associate
student association executive team
and they tirelessly applied managerial
and innovation skills
that made all of their classmates
experience much better
they were fantastic advocates for their
classmates interests
and thoughtful partners with the gsb
administration
faculty and staff thank you to all four
of you
two other two other groups of student
leaders navigated these uncharted times
and adapted to our virtual environment
the arbuckle leadership
fellows and the global exploration the
global explorations leaders
these students devoted their time to
making these programs work
in entirely new ways the gsb community
this year
benefited from their efforts will the
fellows and global explorations leaders
please rise so we can recognize you
this is the end of a journey that was
quite different from what you
anticipated when you began the program
i know that like any gsb class this was
a transformative experience
and your lives have been forever changed
while a lot of the experiences you
envisioned had to be altered and were
constrained
i hope you will look back fondly on your
time at the gsb
i also hope you will stay involved with
the gsb our alumni
played an important role in your
academic experience
ranging from serving as judges in the
executive challenge
to acting as mentors in entrepreneurial
classes
it is my wish that you too will engage
with the gsb's academic mission
as alumni and give your time and
experience generously to future classes
the late rj miller dean of the gsb from
1968 to 1978
founded the certificate in public
management and social innovation
program here at the gsb i was lucky to
get to know rj before he passed away
and i remember just a few years ago as
he neared the age of 100
he would be standing on this stage
enthusiastically
congratulating people at as they
graduated
the certificate program educates leaders
who understand societal issues
design for and evaluate impact and
understand the
specificities of the management of
social organizations
in both the private and public sectors
in a world faced with dire global
in with dire global health equity
and sustainability challenges today's
certificate candidates take the spirit
of our gsb
motto change lives change organizations
change the world to its full potential
this year we have 177 certificate
candidates
their names are listed in the program
congratulations to all of you
we will we will announce graduation
awards at a later time
these awards include recognizing the top
10 of the class as rj miller scholars
the student with the top gsb gpa in the
class as the ford scholar
the robocheck prize in finance and the
arbuckle award
chosen by the graduating class for a
classmate who has best exemplified
the spirit of the gsb
margaret hayes associate dean of the mba
program
will share the pandemic tribute and
introduce the student speakers
after the student speakers the mba
candidates names will be read by kirsten
moss
assistant dean of mba admissions and
financial aid
and jamie shine assistant director of
the career management center
as the students as the graduates walk
across the stage
thank you
you'll notice that in your program we've
shared a tribute to the mba class of
and their unique trials and tribulations
completing their mbas during covid
i encourage you to read the entire
tribute and i'd like to share a brief
excerpt
with you now we have all suffered
loss heartache and feelings of
uncertainty about the future
there are many of you who have lost
family and friends to this pandemic
and to other causes and we all share
that pain
but you rose above it all and focus on
what was important to you
you've come together as a class to
transform
in-person events into successful virtual
and hybrid opportunities
you've kept alive traditions like talk
the climate business and innovation
summit
the healthcare and bbsa conferences
the military service event the sports
innovation speaker series
and the gsb show the screening of the
show provided a fantastic culmination to
this year
right here in frost with those thoughts
in mind i would like to welcome to the
stage ariba kamal
who will share her own tribute to the
class of 2021.
[Applause]
oh
family
[Applause]
on march 6 2020
i was in sweet green eating my nutrient
optimized dinner
like any respectable gs beer when
i got the email
all classes would be moved online
indefinitely
due to the spread of kovind 19.
i remember reading it in disbelief
surely it's an overreaction to shudder
the entire gsb i thought
surely this cannot last beyond a few
days
well i was very wrong
fast forward to june 7 2021
and we are graduating as the band of 400
students
who woke up one morning in 2020 and
confronted
the end of the world as we knew it our
classrooms reduced to grid view on zoo
our town square swaddled in caution tape
our skies scarlet with wildfires
our cities roiling in pain after the
murder of george floyd
our newspaper is brimming with shock
after the insurrection
in washington dc
for me the realization i was inhabiting
and
unfamiliar reality dawned a month before
govind19 stormed our world
in january 2020 i got a call that my
mother
my heart my soul my everything was in
the er
struggling to breathe
i spent the 20-hour flight from san
francisco to pakistan
searching frantically for a ventilator
discovered
on landing in my hometown that my mother
was already dead
then drove from the airport to the
morgue
to the graveyard
then i flew back to the gsb in a bubble
of grief that
expanded and engorged and engulfed the
entire world around me
suddenly everyone around me was also
searching for a ventilator
everyone around me was also struggling
to go on
what does it take to survive
the end of your life as you know it
what does it take to survive change
survive grief
survive a pandemic that wreaks havoc on
lives and organizations
and the entire world
it takes what philosopher jonathan clear
calls
radical hope
radical hope means identifying something
worth fighting for
and someone who will fight with you then
taking
a million small steps forward against
the current
of adversity radical hope means looking
past the darkness you have been plunged
into
towards the future so radiant that it
transcends your ability to fully see
or understand it a future so joyful that
you are compelled
to bring it to life
radical hope is our weapon against
despair even when despair feels
justified
it is something we practice not
something we have
it is the only way as james baldwin puts
it
to seize fleeing reality
and begin changing it
i see radical hope in how gs peers
responded to kobit 19 by creating
projects to deliver
groceries to actress seniors and bundle
unused gift cards for distressed
families
direct crowd-funded paychecks towards
furloughed stanford staff
or martial private sector resources
towards the production of emergency pbne
i see radical hope in how our black
business student association
responded to the gsb action plan for
racial equity by demanding
measurable targets for increasing black
students and tenured faculty
and pointing out that racial justice
means dismantling our own
everyday status goal from hiring
practices at our startups
to housing access in our neighborhoods
i see radical hope in how we all
reimagined
this gsp experience whether it was
jabbing q-tips up our nostrils twice a
week and praying for negative covet
results
or recording banned form performances in
dusty garages or low-key notes in empty
auditoriums
or inventing social traditions ranging
from rollerblading
to team positivity contagion and of
course
zoom talk
i see radical hope as the force that
brought
you and me out of the jaws of fear
and into this amphitheater ensconced in
the kind of
unimaginable strength that stems
from unimaginable strife the kind of
shared bonds
that only stem from shared struggle
the world we re-enter today might feel
darker
than it did two years ago
global poverty increased last year for
the first time
in two decades with up to 500 million
more people
pushed into destitution even as
billionaires worldwide
grew their wealth
it's getting harder to look away from
extreme inequality
or climate change or threats to
democracy but
as amanda gorman would say there is
always light if we are brave enough to
see it
there is always light if we are brave
enough
to be it
starting today you and i
get to leave this magical place with
more power
more privilege and more practice
in radical hope
you and i get to face every challenge
from here on now
fortified with this diploma and guarded
by this community
you and i get to wake up
every morning for the rest of our lives
and ask ourselves how will i use my
radical hope today
to bridge the space between what is
and what should be which injustice
will i tackle which opportunity
will i bring to life
thank you
so
thank you ariba i would encourage all of
us here today to do our very best to
practice radical hope
i certainly hope our graduates will keep
your words close
as they embark on their post-gsb
endeavors
i also hope they will take to heart the
thoughtful advice
shared by our next speaker please join
me in welcoming
emily calkins
in the two years we've called the gsbr
home
perhaps there was not a single phrase
used more commonly
than this one wait for it unprecedented
times
it was the subject line of every
disappointing email the headline
of every horrifying news article it was
the opening
of every speech and to be honest
at many junctures i thought of this
little phrase as encapsulating all the
ways
in which we were wronged constant fear
for our health
worry for the safety of our classmates
anxiety about the well-being
of our families loss of in-person
classes
the crass and sudden destruction of the
experience that we dreamt of
but i've come now to regard it as the
single best piece of evidence
for the idea that we may actually have
gotten so much more out of this place
than we could have dreamed
and here's why the cornerstone of night
management center is emblazoned with the
following phrase
dedicated to the things that haven't
happened yet
and the people who are about to dream
them up
in other words this whole place is for
learning
and then catalyzing unprecedented things
take a second to imagine that the gsb is
literally
all about what is unprecedented
and if we take this to be true i can
think of two major
and pretty darn special lessons and the
first one is this
ironically enough there may there may be
no better way
to prepare for a career and a life
of haven't happened yet things than by
living through one
together it's one thing to imagine
who you will be in the wake of the
unimaginable
it's another to spend two years finding
out for sure
watching yourself pioneer new ways of
working
and learning and loving
to try and summarize the hurt and
anxiety and fear we all felt over the
past two years
would be difficult in such a small space
so i won't
but what i will say is that the world
changed when we were learning
how to change the world and i couldn't
think of a better education
in crisis and empathy and disruption
and leadership it's unsurprising that
the word unprecedented leaves a bad
taste in our mouths
because for the past year it's been
irrevocably intertwined
with bad news and fear and
disappointment
but our cornerstone is a reminder of one
really
important but often forgotten fact
unprecedented can mean good
it can mean powerful and beautiful
and important and overdue yes
in the time we've been at the gsb kovid
has been an unprecedented
global pandemic but let us take a second
to revel in what else was unprecedented
before this year the scale
and scope of calls for racial justice
around this
country and at this school
the election of a vice president who
identifies
as female black asian american
the speed of developing a new
life-saving vaccine
the seven gsb founded startups that
stepped up to provide
coveted relief food access and
protective gear
around our country and the world
the second big lesson is about one tiny
word
the most important word in the whole
cornerstone
and that word is yet this to me
is the cornerstone of the cornerstone my
favorite part
because it's a tiny word with a
humongous amount
of courage and optimism and self-belief
embedded within its tiny three-lettered
walls
no isn't on the menu it's just
yes or soon the cornerstone doesn't say
to crazy dreams it doesn't say to things
that haven't happened
it says to things that haven't happened
yet
as if it were a fortune teller sitting
at the corner of campus
basking in the quiet knowing that we all
might just accomplish
what we came here to do
if you ever find yourself anchored in
what things look like now
let yet be your flotation device
if ever you can't see your own power
clearly
let yet be your mirror if you ever lose
faith
in your dream or company or self
let yet reset you
let's practice at the end of each of the
sentences i'm about to say
i'd like for you all to shout out yet
this includes students faculty admin
staff
parents especially my own family if you
don't participate i'll take it really
hard
okay here we go i haven't started
my company or gotten my dream job
the world doesn't look the way i want it
to in terms of racial justice
equal pay or civil rights
the world doesn't know my name or the
names of my classmates
am not quite the person partner
sibling or leader i want to be
congratulations on surviving what has
been unprecedented
preemptive congratulations on turning
today's dreamy
rough drafts of crazy ideas into the
precedent scenting
setting companies of tomorrow most
importantly and finally remember it's
never
i haven't it's always just i haven't
yet congratulations
abbey
atta
[Applause]
aboud
wes adams
[Applause]
joshua bioden adeoye
esteban aguel mooney
michelle aguinis
clint ackerman
[Applause]
paul mickey apobly
khaled al-abadi
kelsey albright
[Applause]
gemina alvarado press palacios
giovanna alvarez
ruben amar
aneery amen
[Applause]
isabel andrade morellano
brian awiyama
betsy arsey
[Applause]
takara ren ashley
robert ogier
[Applause]
maya abney
eugene i worry
aj aigoon
[Applause]
andrew walker babbitt
katie baker
roberto bandiera de melo
[Applause]
jordan samuel bank
ryan christopher berry
jessica allison barzillai
becky bauer
jacob beck
[Applause]
pele
julie perez
[Applause]
mario bermudez cabeza
alakic bassin
[Applause]
burani
george eleg bokinski
ryan michael bowles
mary borowick
ross bowen
[Applause]
henry bradlow
abby bremen
mackenzie ann brannigan
[Applause]
georgiana kingsbury brook brinkley
nell delahante brodsky
catherine brown
[Applause]
olivia brown
claudio bruno
ankit bhuteraju
[Applause]
mark sebastian bush
emily nichols calkins
[Applause]
matt cavano
lara isabel capalin aguer revere
alexander carlisle
[Applause]
gregory victor caso
dr parul chatra
abby chow
[Applause]
jessica ciao
h
dan rand chen
[Applause]
jennifer ruth chen
laura chen
[Applause]
ashley cho
hey riyang julie joe
jessie choi
[Applause]
whitney chu
kyle clark
[Applause]
renee coggins
matthew colford
janna calucci
[Applause]
alexandra jane cummerford
jane conroy
aaron elizabeth cooney
[Applause]
jorge kadero
audrey austin emling coulter
john crawford
[Applause]
william andrew henry crown
andrew cryer
christie curie
[Applause]
neha de lao
santiago de buen
[Applause]
alicia de smet
julian diego de benedetti
david diver
[Applause]
lucas de wilde
nicholas angelo diamond tony
danielle hannah do good
dostiarova
yuri debzanski
[Applause]
john drago
laura yay rao sorry laura yao ray
do
peter du plessy
john richard dwayne jr
[Applause]
you'd see a elidia guan dupont
juanita duca botero
brian brian arthur eckhardt
nadine elashkar
[Applause]
antonio elisua cantu
jack elzinga
francisco enriquez
[Applause]
anna episode
sebastian espinosa
lauren felice
[Applause]
phone peshwan
eugenio fernandez
rodri fernandez
[Applause]
sarah franzen
chris gertner
[Applause]
neil gandhi
rodrigo garcia
[Applause]
annie garoppolo
christina garrido
anderson gava
kevin gerner
alex victor gersevins
[Applause]
elena angela giannotis
francisca maria carolina gilmore
mariana geraldo moreno
carlotta blatzel
stephen goldberg
will go lincoln
[Applause]
claudio gonzalez
alexa grabel
micah greenberg
[Applause]
benjamin reed gregory
andrew griggs
[Applause]
barry grinberg
peter grogan
joan joan grubb
[Applause]
james benjamin gusberg
mark habib
bridget blair hackler
abdilamid hydar
connor hammond
[Applause]
brendan hanrahan
chelsea harris
nathan case hedgecock
[Applause]
jonathan hess
alfredo inostroza
kevin ho
[Applause]
timothy jordan hogue
may hawkhauser
seth hosemann
[Applause]
nandita hooray
rebecca page hauser
brenton howland
[Applause]
joy huang
lydia hilton
[Applause]
orekase eda
bianca michaela jackson
shawan jackson
[Applause]
nathan michael jacobson
sarah jacobson
alon jaime mizrahi
[Applause]
adesh jane
sophie janaski
raven jeong
[Applause]
jennifer kalidas
ariba kamal
roy kamar
jisha cambo
shilpa kannan
marie christine captain
[Music]
mike katzman
jessica kosciel
emily kazam
[Applause]
dylan kennedy
jeffrey alex kessler
[Applause]
tara jafari karadpir
kanan nadim corey
alex kim
[Applause]
catherine gian kim
edward kingsley
joanna klitsky
daniel levy knapp
michael cobiela
allison kiyomi
[Applause]
lakota
alexander copco
giorgi corelli
[Applause]
abe kumar
vivas kumar
now paran kumata
[Applause]
anna kirkuli
la protana
changing of the all guards
caroline kentur larue
[Music]
alexandra lauer
jessica renee lawson
[Applause]
benjamin lazaroth
ed leathers
june lee
[Applause]
natalia levite
k lee
mona li
[Applause]
timothy george lynn
caroline yuandi ling
christian lipchi
[Applause]
ajah little
stephanie lou
truman lou
nicholas lombardo
pierre looning
[Applause]
jennifer lapada
jenna louie
kristoff lissay
jeffrey mcdonald
spencer mcqueary
[Applause]
edmure maguin
jessica mcgill nick liao
nick muhold
[Applause]
christian douglas manchester
michael martin
[Applause]
valaria martinez
mariana martinez
morrison mast
andrew mattingly
[Applause]
mao do sorry maodi ayunda
kyle mcandrews
[Applause]
[Music]
andrew mccrary
kelly hefner mcfarland
[Applause]
ted mcelveen
erica meehan
[Applause]
alejandra mejia
alexander mendes
[Applause]
jarrell june mendoza
morale menon
alec merkulov
[Applause]
andreina mesa
emily elizabeth miller
joseph mills
[Applause]
matthew milner
eva milo
[Applause]
paula minardi
dominic marabali
nicholas murda
[Applause]
chad mitchell
vicente mubarak
jimmy monaco
olivia moore
[Music]
[Applause]
joseph marcos
jenna morgenstern gaines
susanna wright morris
[Applause]
donald edward muir
eugen nam
badir nasir
adrianne nugreros
[Applause]
michael nemand
stone macking
belinda knew
dan oaks
christopher allman son
[Applause]
kerry amugeli
yuko ono
alexander organ
[Applause]
lorena hostos
jennifer ho lon o'young
lorenz paul huber
kelly paris
[Applause]
geo park
xavier parkman
[Applause]
alicia patel
hardik patel
jed paul
[Applause]
adriana perez benavides
mitchell mccord peterman
lauren phelps
[Applause]
bianca pinasco
roman pinchuk
missy paterd
[Applause]
zachary portnoy
gina puccinelli
[Applause]
ishan sarna puri
[Music]
[Applause]
aiden quilly
michael ramirez gantz
foreign
mary grace roberts reeves
chen you wren
[Applause]
[Music]
luis rengifou
weston lee reynolds
[Applause]
gabe renoso palli
matt rickard
nick roberts
william william robbins
judy romea
janine romey
[Applause]
eliza becker rosen
william leopold ross
[Applause]
lauren rothwell
bob roy
ben ruxin
[Applause]
deepak sabata
nicholas sanchez
brandon sanders
[Applause]
emily savage
olivia ann savettes
andrew jacobs shiner
[Applause]
anna schlesinger
alexander schmidt
ben schneider
[Applause]
beverly c
torey seidenstein
muhammad shafi
[Applause]
daniel shane
susanna hume shattuck
yaniv shimoni
monil singal
[Applause]
caitlyn leverens smith
joe sofia
alyssa song
[Applause]
jacob sparkman
timothy spencer
[Applause]
michelle justine spitzer
aparna sreena
elizabeth houghton star
michael stelton camp
[Applause]
[Music]
phillip james stiefel ii
charles william stone
[Applause]
cameron strong
william sue
ricardo suarez
[Applause]
luisa elena sucre polito
adeline tiffany sawana
[Music]
lucy svaboda
[Applause]
yonga melody tamir
tan
alex 10 credit
nicholas tandy
[Applause]
audium tesla
ubishake thea garage
joseph tisch
christina torres gonzalez
[Applause]
sachi twine
daniel uriba visa
[Applause]
yaritza vargas
ross van heisen
conrad von moltka
[Applause]
matthew wallace
joseph walters
[Applause]
austin william ward
rika watanabe
charlotte claire weiss
[Applause]
tessa wiggin
morgan lee wiley
victoria wills
[Applause]
john wallison
nico woods
eja erdegos wyric
[Applause]
ann yang
peshi yan
joshua young yang
wei yang
soha yes reby
[Applause]
jessica young
tina yee jing yoo
juan pio young
[Applause]
eric zagorski
matthias zenyello
[Music]
[Applause]
zorovski
michael jong
[Applause]
jean jung
jennifer joe
carl ziada
jessica zoe
[Applause]
gsb graduates guests
faculty and staff we have reached the
end
of the 2021 stamford graduate school of
business
graduation and now
before we walk out into the beautiful
california night
let me ask the gsb class of 2021
to please rise
and let's have a big final round of
applause
for the stanford gsb class of 2021
thank you
congratulations to all the graduates
i think it's safe to say there has never
been a class like this one or a journey
like this one through the gsb
and we are so proud of all of you for
having made it to this day
honored yes if you would please wait i'm
going to ask the class of 2021 to rise
and process out through out of frost
amphitheater
and thank you all so much for joining us
today congratulations again class of
[Applause]
[Music]
so